so in say 1996 you had said hey Chris
Verdi go see a new Adam Sandler movie I
would have been like awesome today you
say we're going to see a new Adam
Sandler movie and I'm like blended stars
Adam Sandler and Drew Barrymore they are
teaming for the third times is like
their little unofficial trilogy of
movies in the past they had 50 first
dates and before that the wedding singer
which I actually think might be out of
Sandler's best straight comedy because I
kind of view his movies having two
different things you have like reign
over me punch-drunk love and Spanglish
over there in there more dramatic comedy
area then you just have a straight-up
comedies like Billy Madison happy
gilmore wedding singer I think might be
the best of the bunch and this comes
from the director of the wedding singers
this movie actually has a little bit
going for it I was walking into this
movie thinking I really hope this isn't
awful but let's see what happens in the
filming of Adam Sandler drew barrymore
they both have a lot of kids and their
single parents through a strange turn of
events they get to go on a trip to
Africa and they end up going together
and of course they hate each other and
of course you know after a while they're
not going to eat each other it's gonna
be all sweet and more romantic and
hopefully it won't be awful is it awful
no thank goodness this is not a
jack-and-jill this is not even that's my
boy this is actually one of Adam
Sandler's better movies of recent years
he still has excellent chemistry with
Drew Barrymore they work well together
you know they're very sweet and cute to
see together on screen you've done it
three times already 50 first dates was
you know it was an okay movie and the
wedding singer I actually like this
movie it's okay you know it's kind of
it's like not quite 50 first dates it's
like underneath that but it's not awful
so in a strange way this might be the
happiest I'm ever going to appear in a
technically negative review because I'm
not really going to recommend that you
rush out and see blended but it's really
not that bad it had some sweet moments
it did have some moments in which I did
laugh but it also has Adam Sandler's
brand of random unnecessary stuff that
just seems like okay that's that's in
the movie now I guess Terry Crews pops
up every once in a while for actually a
very funny role throughout the movie
that I did enjoy there are a few cameos
and some likeable performances Kevin
Nealon plays Kevin Nealon in every Adam
Sandler movie he says one word
in like a kind of inspirational way take
the ball to its home to its home why
didn't you go to your home s your home
that's your home here's a nice piece of
old man Clemens is gonna when
he realizes it who got a lighter Oh
doesn't have any memorable lines like
that in the film but it does have good
chemistry it has some sweet moments it
does have some likable performances in
the movie and Adam Sandler actually has
a few scenes in the film that kind of
matter you know there's some nice
touching father-daughter type stuff
going on and some mother-son type stuff
going on as well some of the kids were
cute but Drew Barrymore's older son was
so annoying in this movie and he really
got on my nerves the film isn't that
funny
but it's you could sit and watch it you
know it's actually not terrible and I
can't really recommend this film because
it's not really that good of a movie
it's very predictable it's very sappy at
times a lot of the jokes do fall flat it
is over long by probably 20 minutes some
of the characters in the film are very
annoying I'm gonna give blended a C+
it's actually not that bad but I
wouldn't really recommend you rush out
and see it I would say maybe catch it
sometime on cable it's a surprisingly
okay movie I was actually shocked so
guys let me know what you thought of the
movie if you have seen it or if you were
going to see it what's your favorite
Adam Sandler film like I said I break
them up into two different things my
favorite of his straight comedies is
probably the wedding singer quite
possibly happy gilmore my favorite of
his more serious roles is definitely
punch-drunk love thanks as always for
watching guys and if you liked this you
can click right here and get stuck my
nice
you guys are just really you know that
my shutterstock promotion is still
running this is a very cool website for
independent filmmakers because a lot of
you guys have messaged me saying can you
look at my short film can you look at
this scene what do you think of my
script and although I can't always watch
or read all of those things I really
appreciate that you guys do take the
time to send those things to me and this
is a very cool website because it allows
you to use stock footage and stock
imagery of very HD and high quality
things like you know over a city from a
helicopter and stuff a lot of this is
submitted by professional filmmakers and
it's legal and through me if you use the
promotion code Chris 5:1 4 you can get
20% off your membership and I hope you
guys do check that out because I enjoy
using that website because sometimes you
just can't get that awesome shot that
you have in your head and you're not
going to be able to until you have a
giant budget and more making Hollywood
films like I hope all of you who want to
can but that website allows you to
legally use awesome stuff like that so
check that out please shutterstock.com
promo code Chris 5:1 for thanks guys